reject nation guys
my hair looks
good right now it will soon be destroyed
by me wearing headphones so this is
gonna be the longest intro ever it's
time to soften your braid so now let's
get to it guys leave a like if you can
because guess what we're watching the
sixth episode of peacemaker learn after
reading a play on the coen brothers burn
after reading subscribe and click the
notification bell go notify when our
reaction for the next peacemaker episode
is up full length
where you sync up with the time code as
always or over at our patreon page
become a superject today by checking out
all the kinds of crap we cover over
there lastly them handsome boys over at
prepper constantly touching themselves
while they're editing down the
highlights with us oh you guys
you perverts that's why we do it
[Music]
hardcore hand me my gun
she knows she was walking around to
peace make his x-ray vision helmet on
he's not gonna like that he's touchy
about his helmets what the [ __ ] she got
one too i confronted him he came clean
my people came to earth because our
planet was dying and one in golf she's
our leader she well she had a vagina
aliens got vagina
we liked it here we were gonna live out
our lives but then goth and the others
started planning for what how to
dominate your world
i was the sole dissenter they said i was
oversensitive you're over-sensitive
you took over someone yes yeah you
killed someone whoever merm really what
i needed to stop them so i inhabited the
worst person i could find this man leota
he's
ah makes sense he's murderer
but still i know his thoughts he's
even he could have changed i took his
freedom and his face
and every day i dread waking up to his
memories
we need to be sure they don't move the
cow before we find it the cow yes
what cow you forgot to tell her about
the cow do you really want it
we're talking about a there's a real cow
okay
all right kids and that's how i defeated
kite man
dangerous villains with only my two
fists my desert eagle and two rocket
launchers any questions
[Laughter]
have you ever met a flash yeah i meant
the flash like everybody else has ever
met him i thought it was unbearable
d-bag
yeah rubik's cube world champion 2025
why is your pet's name so unoriginal why
are you my least favorite kid in this
class because i can see right through
you and i think you're a loser
shoot him yeah
jamil's kid
do you have an origin story
trigger point man
who the [ __ ] you killed it
the wrong kid died
that's my mom she used to bartend in the
starlight lounge becky cool is yeah
that's right i haven't seen her in like
10 years god i think you might be my
real dad
[Laughter]
shit's about to accelerate last night i
took all the evidence to a judge you
took what the what and i was issued an
arrest warrant for christopher smith our
new key suspect in the murder of annie
sterphausen we can rightly have two
people in jail for the same crime
you have got no
idea what you're [ __ ] with here he
does not look happy you really go
through this stuff huh
i'm trying to swipe some more
oh
they're buddies now
i love its sensitivity to the animals
we're gonna approach with caution
surround the trailer and enter easy this
is gonna be crazy
that's not gonna go well
don't kill a bunch of cops peacemaker
don't kill our favorite cops at least
dude you still have that thing yeah
he tried to kill us and he cut off half
my toe yeah sometimes i just think i'm
insecure in my masculinity so i'm making
up for it by having a dangerous pet
oh damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
one tap is yes two taps is no do you
understand
is that a peace sign
what's your favorite color dude it's
it's yes or no question
is your favorite color teal bro what the
[ __ ] praying mantis thing has a favorite
color and it might unexpectedly be teal
that is mildly interesting but he just
drew a peace sign in the jar don't we
want to see what's up with that
yes we do
why did you put a peace sign on the job
please
i see how you are your preferred
conversation partners are italy and goth
neither of who are capable of speech try
introspection on that [ __ ] i do
surround myself with things that don't
talk back and maybe i just shouldn't
blame yourself dude [ __ ] i'm talking
listen
i'm getting this weird feeling that
you're angry
[Applause]
i feel you crisp
what's so urgent if you're at home get
the [ __ ] out the police are gonna be
there any second with an arrest warrant
i'll grab goff
it's time to bring a piece yeah
i don't know how many cops i gotta kill
again
this is the evergreen police department
open the door and come out with your
hands up now
this is the evergreen
come out now stay low i'm taping off to
me so i have both hands free
hurry up adrian
oh god what if they find the diary
[ __ ] oh the diary
what the
hell
eagley
thought we could waste it
what
[Music]
oh
what have you done no
no no no no no
no no
what have you done no
no what
oh you should have taken here
oh yay
yes my dude
there's a car for you over there hill
who are you do you want to ask stupid
questions where do you want to live
which ones you want to do
[Laughter]
nice and hard now
well that's not right
no
[ __ ] dude no no [ __ ] up we can track
these things no dude no [ __ ] dude
it was a secure phone you can't [ __ ]
track it it's a pretty big [ __ ] up on my
part [ __ ] man
i had a [ __ ] up super cute pieces of
eagerly on there man they're
irreplaceable
just as the shooter was running away
peacemaker
oh no no caucasian man about five and a
half feet tall red hair
striped shirt with a red tie
had a black mask and
i think it was a
talk about the hamburglar
hey this is gonna sound weird but i
think locke was just describing the
[ __ ] hamburglar
striped shirt red tie fedora black mask
easter eggs hey you have a diary no they
found one in your trailer [ __ ] i got
a notepad but i barely ever use it [ __ ]
that we got a bit of an issue
yeah we kept goff you can't cough
because peacemaker is masculinity issues
it's like a knuckle dick's tiger i
didn't trust you guys and i kept him
because i wanted answers and i knew he
wasn't gonna get out but then he got out
and took over an oriental woman asian
oh not supposed to be oriental anymore
asian why
nobody knows why it's just bad
i do feel that she was fond of you
oh sophie you sure but in the end this
is better for everyone
what is just enjoy the moment
it's like the terminator learning how to
smile
oh
boy
whoa
no
i see a body count coming
oh he's gonna put the suit on
oh my goodness sam
oh damn they're gonna possess the whole
police station
oh
damn
come on come on come on fitz that's out
of a shot
damn it
they really make this seem like a really
painful process yeah
oh
oh oh no
wow
they're all practicing their smiles
[Laughter]
look another nazis but that's a pretty
badass cause
you know context aside yeah
oh
carving the dove a piece
it's a p90 i put a double piece on it
for you
no it's facing the wrong way
tail should be on the right
super nice though thank you
here you go
i don't think i really care about the
double piece i just think i said that
because i don't want to kill people
anymore
wow i know when we first met i said i
thought you were a total piece of [ __ ]
but
i don't think that anymore 85 a piece of
[ __ ] maybe but the rest of you is
tonight chris
amelia
good night amelia oh god i've always
wanted to do that stop in my tracks just
look over my right shoulder
no
full body
your day will come
nobody's actually playing this
among many items found in the search of
christopher smith's home
was a diet
what the [ __ ] written by the suspect
oh dory
maintains that the world is inhabited by
aliens find
and stop the peacemaker
by whatever means necessary what the
[ __ ]
god damn that is intense yeah
the next episode is gonna be crazy yeah
it's gonna be a nationwide manhunt
it's gonna be with the students you
think it's a good guess maybe vigilante
questions
all right well you're one for one
we'll see if you're saying two for two
now
that would make more sense because i
don't know how much they'd let the kids
improvise
how much it led john cena just installed
a bunch of children
i wouldn't put it past honestly though
like i wouldn't put it past and that
would be that scene
because there's so much other curve
balls and things you could do
sad look set
does this look sad
hey
[Music]
oh
look at you
that was crazy this looks like they used
a blooper and just cut out all the
filmmakers laughing and [ __ ]
exactly
damn we were both wrong about that one
that was unexpected
constantly subverting expectations
brilliant
whoa whoa whoa don't trailers for the
next episode i won't see anything
all right guys let's talk about it
another great setup man goth had me
going i thought goth might have been
like
where's peacemaker in the doofus or
whatever you said uh because
i was like and he did the peace sign so
i i was thinking maybe maybe this
butterfly is having like some type of
change of heart
and is wanting to help we still don't
know what their full intent is do we no
not really looks like world domination
certainly
one of those plots of aliens like our
planet was destroyed so we need to you
know marine goes into it but it feels
like our planet was destroyed and it
seems like the only place we could
repopulate would be here yeah it's kind
of perfect organisms to take over yeah
but humans suck yeah but we will use
your hosts to create studies and
experiments on us yeah but i feel like
it'll be something a little bit more to
that i mean that was a diabolical plan
is it while we're working with it that's
what it seems like now i mean now i'm
wondering does waller have one in her
because of how like how they would do
that you know mess with the dc universe
a little too much yeah but you know you
got to suspect anybody who's a little
deadpan i mean walter seems like she
would do that
yeah it seems like she at least wanted
to pinpoint the crimes on or or maybe
they improvised on it with the diary
knowledge
maybe because it sounds like what walter
wanted to do regardless was
on chris yeah yeah pinned this all on
him ultimately as like which sounds like
a wall sanity yeah totally
damn that's real that's real messed up
mm-hmm that's some crazy reveals though
man that's some crazy reveals you got
sophie
becoming the butterfly i didn't see that
moment coming at all yeah that was a
they definitely put those characters
front and center for the end of the show
every i mean they really james gunn
especially knows how to really ramp up
the tension here
with uh
intermingling comedy i felt like
vigilante is stupider than usual
today yeah yeah like you're like
obnoxiously dumber you seem to find like
uh he he wrote like a finer line before
and this time i'm like oh you're like
way down this episode like dumb dumb not
like quirky dumb yeah certain moments
quirky dumb but still capable yeah
there's certain moments where it's like
you're just entirely oblivious yeah yeah
yeah
um which i feel like is a pit easy
pitfall to fall into with a character
like that is how do we keep him
dumb always on the right level you know
yeah yeah but that seems like they
dumbed him down a lot for the sake of
the comedy beats yeah to really foil to
really drive a wedge between him and
chris it feels like it's a really
create some problems in their escape and
all that it is interesting learning too
about i mean a lot of this
everyone has like some type of inner
conflict happening here but you know at
the kick of it with mern you have your
cliffhanger there or like merm bad
butterfly but as i suspected as many of
us did is that while being a butterfly
he's not like the rest of them i feel
like his intentions are
true i feel like they're authentic
of what he's at least expressing and
motivating this team to do i think that
there's a little bit of a wrench in it
is that waller plan with the diary but
he didn't know about the diary um
but when it comes to
uh what he was saying about humans and
stuff and it explains his character too
with his background
of like who murn the mercenary was and
why he was such a threat and to know
that at one point he took over after all
that
and sees faith in humanity and sees the
capacity for growth
and how people can change and reflecting
on him and why he's more
expressive about his emotions now more
sensitive he's the emotional one yeah
yeah and you do you do see that which i
i thought was interesting to see that
like
pretty much the other two companions
harcourt and um
not diabetes economos yeah and economos
both already know about it
and you know it also does show this
level of trust that harcourt does put
out there it's like we know she's a got
a tough exterior but there's a softie
underneath those layers
and you're this this show's been peeling
back what's really underneath the
surface for all these characters
and man john cena he just
knocks it out of the park he's so good
yeah like i love those
um
internal expositional lines that he just
spits out
i think
i think i'm acting out because i don't
want to kill people anymore yeah or even
that whole thing about uh why he has the
pets about masculinity yeah yeah yeah or
when he's talking with vigilante about
like i just write i don't have any
i don't have any friends who i can like
who can talk back to me yeah yeah but it
just gets more more angry as it goes but
this episode seemed to deal when you
look at the opening scene with john cena
you know doing that thing where it's
like a hero's attending class today and
he's never been really looked at as a
hero there's a lot of criticism towards
what he stands for what his actions are
his viewers are criminal more than
anything else
and when he's doing one of those things
we're talking to you know students in
the classroom and you know getting asked
questions about being a hero and even
the way how he reacts and responds to
things and even the question about his
origin story how that's rooted in a way
where he feels like he really messed up
and killed his own brother by accident
or we actually haven't really even
explored how that all went down yet
maybe it was intentional i don't think
it wasn't it sounded could be i mean it
seems like an accident but in a
situation where like what did you expect
yeah you know you it seems like augie
certainly like made him fight each other
or do something really crazy and violent
and it's like you know he's he could
easily die in the process
but yeah but with the chara but with
with peacemaker it seems
that this show is going out of its way
to show how we gotta slowly strip him
down from
you know the
like him and adebayo they both live in
the shadows of their dominant parent
you know that's a big part of why i
think they confide in each other and why
there's a level of empathy that adebayo
had towards chris more than anyone else
on the team she can sympathize for him
in a lot more ways when she sees where
he comes from
and the rule the subconscious rule
chris's father has on him kind of like
what happens with her as well
and like this whole
their whole thing deals with you know
parental
traumas and learning to break free from
their upbringings
so
with chris we've slowly been having him
become more vulnerable understanding
more of why he is the way he is and now
realizing that whole thing that would
like with rick flag a peacemaker what a
joke how
yeah the identity that he thought he was
you know putting out there was something
that was heroic but really isn't heroic
and he doesn't want to kill people
anymore he's having a crisis about that
so this is like a an identity crisis a
hero image symbolism crisis that he's
going through
and it's done in some real poetic ways i
really appreciated the piano scene of
how he just it's a little playp you know
for like two minutes right now yeah and
it's another one i mean i feel like
every week there's a new reason to be
like john cena man i liked him before
but now but but even that like i love
that they took the time this episode
it's like it's lighter on needle drops
and the and not that that's technically
a needle drop but you know like they
really let the musical centerpieces play
and i thought that was really wonderful
too because you know like usually there
are ways to frame that out and it seemed
like he really put in the time to at
least learn the fingering of the piece
to sell it and yeah like to have an
actual moment of unexpected you know
like an unexpected talent to emerge but
also one that comes out in a moment of
contemplation i thought was really was
like a really like lovely and
sophisticated choice for a show like
this you know that does so much in the
irreverent and in the bombastic
uh you know not that you know that's not
well within the sort of subversion that
we're doing with him but that was a
really nice moment and especially after
like a little
piece of bonding with harcourt
you know and and i mean like to
juxtapose the two like i think that's a
really good point of yeah you have him
at a bio in oddly similar positions even
though they're so different in the way
they express and i thought her scene
with keo was one of my favorites of the
episode like i love just the the nuance
they have coming from her and i'm really
curious to see where she's gonna end up
given who her mom is by the end of the
season and all that i mean if they're
arching she has to stand up to her she
has to yeah
or like
he's triggered
he'd probably confess the truth to
kristen yeah
that's what this show's been doing is
you know like we know peace man i think
i've said this before peacemaker suicide
squad shows peacemaker this is showing
us chris
and i i love it man it's it's it's a
beautiful show in a lot of it's so it's
weirdly beautiful yeah and also too like
really tight on on the plotting i feel
like like this was still pretty intense
even though this feels like the pivot
from act two deck three episode like it
does still feel palpably uh
intense and having it be that you have
this mass scale invasion
opposed with this very grassroots just
nasty uprising of these white
supremacists coming together like
there's such
disparate elements and i'm really
excited to see how they all crash and
make a holy mess by the time the finale
rolls around one thing i did want from
this show leading in though
was a little bit more of
the [ __ ] up side of peacemaker to put
it lightly
the the side i mean even if it's like
done through flashbacks of you know like
the the thing that was always marketed
uh i care more about peace than anything
else i'm willing to kill any man woman
or child again to achieve it and i
wanted to see a little bit more of that
i see like a truly disturbing peace
operation at some point yeah what he
considers like bringing the peace
yeah because it seems like for most of
the show he while he you know he has
anti-hero qualities it feels like for
the most part they have made him pretty
easy to like and so yeah i can i can
share that for sure yeah
maybe maybe just in the form of like
flashbacks or talking about things he
actually did that he thought were
like reflecting back on it you know yeah
you see like oh damn our character did
some messed up things in the past yeah
yeah after all this journey we've been
on can i still like him by hand yeah and
knowing what
seeing how he is haunted by those those
things because you know vigilante calls
them out on it all the time in like
humorous ways of like we kill the bad
guys and you know sometimes we kill the
wrong guy but we just brush it off like
it happens you know and uh i want i
wanted to see some of that like what are
like the men women and children that he
killed in order to achieve peace
because it seems like he has done that
he's pretty confident in doing it with
the suicide squad it was like a
no-brainer yeah yeah yeah you know even
killing brick flag was like he didn't
want to but he was willing too
yeah he did what he had to
or like eating every dick on that beach
yeah it would be cool that freaking
bloodsport showed up at one point yeah i
mean that would be epic yeah i mean any
uh like really any of that i would love
to see
daniella melchior tweeted something
about you know like wanting to come and
bring some love to just on twitter or
whatever but like any of them i would
love to see show up well i i think what
they've been doing here is while they've
been stripping chris down
now the public is after him and
the uh the whole police force and the
nazis are after him too
his own father's after him like
literally it's it's like internal and
external forces are all collapsing in on
him right as he is becoming a new person
and as he was feeling like he was part
of a team
uh he'd no longer trust that team
because they're clearly hiding stuff
from him and they don't even know how to
like lie anymore like that's like what's
going on dude you think we're stupid but
i can tell something's going on and like
the way they're all looking at each
other it's like you're letting on so
much that you're clearly hiding
something from it i like that i like
that bit a lot and that it doesn't get
resolved this episode i thought that was
a really nicely hewn bit of
inter character tension and turmoil to
be
just just immersed in yeah of like ah
like it does hurt because so much of the
fun and so much of the joy has been oh
man they actually are building this team
and now they're yeah still all these
different deceits still
ready to come out
from pretty much everybody but economist
which uh yeah it's yeah he's this is a
really good ensemble piece
and what they did establish too though
is that you know when the butterflies
take over the brains they they retain
all the information and knowledge
and the experiences of whatever the host
is
so you know like that's what i think
creates a good level of stakes too with
that cop who is working with our team
the the like
villainous cop or whatever oh chris
heyerdahl yeah yeah him um
because yeah once he's taken over all
that information they have access to now
yeah so like it's all gonna i feel like
we're gonna
lean into some type of catastrophe of a
situation something that's gonna be
massive oh yeah and i'm looking forward
to it so much i think that i think this
was like one of those episodes did a
really good job on progressing the plot
progressing our characters
at the same time really setting up
something major to come like the
direction of this has been so clean but
god damn listen
eagerly murdering people or at least
knocking them out in violent ways
was awesome
the center piece of the entire thing
don't underestimate that eagle ever
constantly where that eagle's gonna get
shot down
i thought it was gonna happen that's not
gonna happen at that moment yeah i was
like oh my god here it comes sacrifice
like is he gonna take the bullet for
peacemaker like that's what i thought
was gonna happen with the cop showdown
uh when they were holding holding him at
gunpoint i thought that's what was
happening but no we didn't go that way
i'm oh i'm holding out two episodes left
we we can make it with a living eagle
by the end
i think the reason why the writing of
james gunn is so
can be
even if i don't like every i i like
clearly like pretty much all of it
though if i have like a slight criticism
here or two i think what really shines
through his work is that he loves his
character so much as if he loves people
yeah you know like that that care for
them and the introspective ways and
examination
is something that i think shines through
his work generally
um this this way of like simp this uh
yeah this just care
about them it's not just like what are
some character development beats it's
it's a true like
he likes them and he cares about them
yeah and that always shows
so
yeah and the freaking uh i do hope we
get to see james gunn's girlfriend doing
it with john cena in this show yeah yeah
gorilla arm dick
she's such a great character though yeah
she's such a great actress yeah she's
awesome i love i love any time she's on
screen yeah she's she has so much
personality underneath that deadpan and
and it's great that that both can exist
at the same time yeah yeah
i'm ready for some badass stuff but guys
what'd you think about this episode
leave it down below
subscribe hit that bell leave a like
last but not least let's do a page
mikhail linden if there's a white dragon
at this patreon it's gotta be you
because you're probably the whitest
person who subscribes to us
because you fly majestically into the
sky much like
a dragon not to be confused with any
other kind of dragon you have
wings that soar you have heat and
passion that comes from your breath
and uh and you're not a racist
and that's the key part
michael lyndon
this is uh
this is my what i want to do to
communicate to you today is uh you you
just you're you're so
wonderfully
i can just feel your eyes burning into
the side of my head much like mikhail's
dragon flames and i wish you were my dad
i feel like you would make me tougher as
a person and and we could rejoice in our
whiteness together because that's some
things we don't get to do as white
people any longer it used to be okay and
now we're not allowed anymore michael
and i'm
authentically upset about that it's
happening i have no idea
i just started running and here we are
now
mikhail you're a good guy and i love you
and don't
pay attention to anything just gonna cut
the camera do that
[Music]